hey guys I'm back to answer another
question someone wanted to know my
opinion on psyllium husk is it is it
good to take is it bad to take so what
is it it's basically a fiber from a
plant called plant Tago about I okay
it's actually the hulls which is the
outer coating around that whole thing it
gives a laxative effect
it's normally for constipation it
absorbs a lot of water because it's 70%
Seibel fiber okay so you have two types
of fiber you have the soluble fiber and
the inside low fiber soluble fiber is
eaten by microbes it's called a
prebiotic now I looked up several
studies and there was some conflicting
studies one of the studies I found I'm
gonna put a link down below shows that
it actually cost colon cancer other
studies showed that it decreases the
risk for cancer so it's kind of a mixed
bag there but here's my opinion on
psyllium husk overall I look at it as a
refined fiber because there's no
nutrients there's no vitamins minerals
trace minerals phytonutrients so my
thoughts are this why not kill two birds
with one stone get your fiber and your
nutrients from the same food vegetables
so I want to thank you for being here
and watching my videos if you haven't
already subscribed go ahead and do so so
you can stay informed of future videos